we are good in our comfort zones but the
moment we start to go blue ocean around
our next level of mastery our fears come
up because we're going out into the
unknown it's human victims love making
excuses and if you recite your excuses
long enough you actually think they're
gonna be true only release Sistine
Chapel ceiling level products to the
world need motivation watch a top 10 of
belief nation what's up at 7 my one word
is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see exploded onto the
world so let's get your motivation to
attend and get you believing in you grab
a snack and chew in today's lessons from
a man who went from being a litigation
lawyer up until age 25 to becoming a
best-selling author trainer and
motivational speaker he's Robin Sharma
and here's my take on his top ten rooms
the success volume 3 enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one my personal favorite don't
fit in the traits that make you strange
or the gifts that make you special and
so I know you're different because you
wouldn't be here with me now if you
didn't feel you're different
you probably don't fit in with most
conversations I sure don't fit in with
most conversations I don't know a lot
about most things that most people talk
about because I don't participate in the
majority right I don't participate in
the news I don't like to gossip I like
to encourage people versus diminish
people I like to be productive versus
busy I like to be creative versus
complacent I like to create value versus
take from other people I like to move
into my present and future versus get
stuck in the past
I like to be fast versus move too - too
slow I like to be a leader versus a
victim I like to believe in possibility
versus get stuck in rational thinking
because you know the instinct is so much
more powerful than intellect and all I'm
suggesting to you is simply this it's
the very things that make you different
that make you authentic and if you don't
fit in I just want to share with you
I've never fit in and the very nature of
anyone who's living a visionary life and
you are living a visionary life no
matter what you're doing let's like it
trapped in labels oh I'm just a coder
I'm just a receptionist in at a at a
restaurant or or in an organization I'm
just a yoga teacher I'm just a gym
manager I'm just a chef in a restaurant
I'm just to teach you people always say
this when I interact with them on the
social media I'm just an entrepreneur
I'm just a student no you're not I'm
just a mom I'm just a dad no you're not
just you're very special
there are no extra people on the planet
today I just want to save you and
validate for you and encourage you those
things that other people might not get
those are
your gifts you might be awkward
awesome you see the world through a
different lens Steve Wozniak who was on
my stage at the Titan summit Zurich the
co-founder of Apple one of the best
people I've ever met he would not have
been able to create the Apple platforms
and products that he created if he
didn't see the world through a different
set of eyes Steve Jobs saw the world
through a different set of eyes Travis
kalanick of uber saw the world through a
different set of eyes Jeff Bezos of
Amazon saw possibility let me have an
online store that initially sells books
John F Kennedy Martin Luther King jr.
mother Teresa Rosa parts jean-michel
Basquiat Beethoven Michelangelo who did
the Sistine Chapel and in Florence David
Yodas Salk
Tesla we could just go on and on and on
and on these people were misunderstood
because the nature of a genius is to not
fit in rule number 2 hire a players Bill
Gates was asked what was the winning
formula of Microsoft when Microsoft was
really the heavyweight champion of their
industry I think they're a little lost
right now but the larger point again is
he replied with this
what made Microsoft Microsoft was not
our software what made Microsoft
Microsoft was our hiring I just want to
suggest to you the second point or trait
of a world-class company is their
ability to hire a players here is the
brain tattoo I want you to absolutely
hardwired in to your business philosophy
as a leader you cannot build an A level
company with c-level talent if your
company is not winning in your field
right now you'll likely have weaknesses
in your hiring don't just
hire people because it's the easiest
move to make a lot of companies spend
very little time on hiring and then most
of their time managing their hiring
mistakes and you know if you're building
a business if you're not too preneur if
your manager if you're CEO like a lot of
the people who watch these mastery
sessions and come to my live events you
know I'm speaking truth here so you
really want to nail your hiring rule
number three let go of your excuses
I've been evangelizing one particular
message for two decades and it's you can
lead without a title you know the
seduction of society is that you have to
have formal power to make a difference
and that's just a lie
the world has sold us the reality is you
can lead without a title and really the
difference or the defining trait of a
leader is you shift from victimhood see
victims love making excuses and if you
recite your excuses long enough you
actually think they're gonna be true I
see it around the world you know people
saying these things like I don't have
time to run or I don't I'm not good
enough to be great of my work or this
would never work or I don't live in the
right country or a life is hard and the
more you recite those excuses you think
they're true so let go of your excuses
start getting some results done and over
time you're gonna rise to your
world-class rule number four DC the
lemon wedges one of the things about the
95 percent a lot of them are complaining
they're making excuses they want epic
lives but they're stuck in the group of
soup the cult of superficiality the top
5% the titans the icons the a players
the world builders are very different
they are not about superficiality they
are all about granularity literally they
have deseeded the lemon wedges this is a
metaphor that I teach basically I was at
a at a hotel in Luzerne Switzerland and
I love fresh lemon tea and when they
brought the tray to me I noticed that in
the tray was two lemon halves or and
they someone in the kitchen had
the time to de-seed the lemon wedges
they actually deseeded them and when I
study f1 teams and I actually had the
privilege to be right with the team at a
recent f1 and what I realized is f1
almost like no other sport is really
about deseeding 11 wedges it was the
smallest granular detail the smallest
calibration that could make the
difference between a top one and a tenth
place finish I really want you to think
about that
I really want to think about f1 f1 is
won or lost in milliseconds because each
lap if you get a little bit faster and
you do it with the consistency because
consistency is the mother of mastery
that is the difference between first
place and not even placing and so if you
look at the top 5% they are all about
deseeding the lemon wedges if you look
at the top 5% they're all about
calibration and people might
misunderstand you and say are you
obsessive why do the details matter and
all you have to do is smile and say
because the details matter and if you
study Beyonce study the great athletes
you study the great f1 drivers and teams
they do deceive the lemon wedges they do
calibrate the Pomodoro they get OAD that
brain tattoo I've become really well
known across the planet for an obsessive
attention to detail OAD
that's what makes the best hotels the
best entrepreneurs the best teams the
market leaders the best restaurants the
best hotels the best cars the best
products the best user experiences all
in line they are sweating the tiniest
seemingly innocuous innocuous details to
create over time a user experience that
clay it creates a go global base of
fanatical followers rule number 5 be
comfortable in the unknown out of my
brain tattoos that I'm become very well
known for is no one will believe in you
until you believe in you and so good
people often become seduced by the
chatter of Theroux loudest
and what I mean by that is we come up
with a great idea let's say it's to
start a project that will allow you to
lead your field let's say it's an idea
for a new product that will allow you to
grow new company let's say you come up
with an idea for a new painting if you
are an artist let's say it's an idea
that will allow you to take your fitness
and your wellness and your longevity to
a whole new level of Wow and pretty
shortly after you come up with the idea
your ego starts screaming because we are
good in our comfort zones but the moment
we start to go blue ocean around our
next level of mastery our fears come up
because we're going out into the unknown
it's human you know if you were looking
to look at the psycho biology of it and
you were study the pure biology that
there's a term called homeostasis human
beings are hard-wired for a steady state
and that kept us alive so literally our
heartbeats around the same amount you
know the 72 beats per minute and their
blood pressure is within a small
bandwidth and that allows us to survive
but what happens is when we come up with
a new idea and when we see a new
opportunity and we start to leave our
comfort zones into the zone of the
unknown where greatness lives we get
scared in the true heroes and the true
Titans and the true masters those people
are not fearless those are people who
have just practiced walking into their
fear and living on the razor's edge
consistently to the point where they're
comfortable amid their discomfort that's
the great opportunity for you not to
avoid fear but to be comfortable in the
unknown to be comfortable when you're
terrified and that really is what the
great artists the great entrepreneurs
the great titans and the great masters
are very good on doing so the first
reason good people lose is their faith
is not as strong as their fear or to put
it a bit more elegantly their fears are
larger than their faith and so it would
be tactical for you how do you build
more faith while you you do what you're
a frightened
and it's a practice you know a great
athlete practices every morning and a
great producer practices walking into
their fears every single day and what
I'm encouraging you to do is every
single day do one thing that causes your
palms to sweat every single day start
training your brain to hunt for
opportunities to step into that unknown
where possibility lives and if you keep
on doing it you're literally going to
build some new neurological hardwiring a
new mental a new pathway in your brain
where you become it becomes easier
because as you know so well all change
is hard at first and it's messy in the
middle and it's beautiful at the end
rule number six only release magic you
want to if you want to have a
world-class company release only magic
another way I could put it only release
Sistine Chapel ceiling level products to
the world Steve Jobs said it beautifully
he said I wanted the icons on the iPhone
to be so beautiful people would want to
lick the screen I had a senior leader
show up at one of my leadership events
and he said you know Robin Steve Jobs
was like that I actually went to his
house and met him shortly before he died
and he didn't look very well but he
didn't want to talk about his physical
condition he just wanted to talk about
the product we were launching he was so
mono maniacally focused on the user
experience he literally wanted to
everything to be flawless that was Steve
Jobs is brilliance and obsession I saw
an incredible interview with Johnny I've
by Charlie Rose in in that Johnny I've
who you know is the design genius behind
a lot of the Apple products he said you
know I knew Steve Jobs and I were
spiritual brothers when we were in a
store one day and Steve Jobs said to me
he goes hey come on over Johnny you got
to see this and I believe from the
interview I believe this is what they
said but they were looking at an
and Steve Jobs said look at how the
sharp point of the arrow is attached to
this part and look how seamless it is
and look at the engineering and I wonder
how they did that and Johnny I've said
Steve Jobs was just in the pocket of the
engineering and beauty behind that piece
of artistry
they were looking at rule number seven
used the 9091
rule so for the next 90 days your first
90 minutes at work make it focused on
your single most important project I'll
repeat that again for the next 90 days
the first 90 minutes of your work day
focus monomaniacal e on your single most
valuable project I call it your
game-changing move so it might be it
might be creating a new piece of code
that will revolutionize the marketplace
it might be a new product that when you
launch it will fill a need within your
industry that no peer is currently
providing I don't know what your game
changing move is but this is your poetry
this is your magnum opus for the next 90
days so what most people do is you know
people who are playing at victimhood
people who are in the ninety five
percent people who are making excuses
about ordinary results in their life a
lot of them are not doing the things
that would give them legendary results
and what they do is they get to the
office and rather than using prime time
for a activities they use their best
hours watching dancing cats on whatever
it is whatever the video platform is
they spend their best hours surfing the
internet looking at blogs they spend
their best hours playing with
notifications reading notifications
chatting with friends who are not really
their friends but really they're just
bored so they're distracting themselves
which is just a far emetic
because potential unexpressed turns to
pain and they're in a lot of pain and
it's subconscious and they haven't done
the work to know it so really they've
created these drugs of choice like too
much email too much web surfing too much
chit chatting too much looking at
funny-looking videos that make them
laugh in the moment that make them feel
happy and give them a short burst of
dopamine and maybe a little bit of
serotonin which is the pleasure
neurotransmitter and that's how they get
through their day and all I'm saying is
there's so much distraction available to
you out there that if you are not
acutely careful it will dominate your
days what I'm really trying to say is
this a ritual for you to run and dial in
and hardwire to the point of
automaticity
that's the word the researchers use when
a habit becomes your new normal over 66
days is the 1991 rule and to give it to
you again so you really remember it for
the next 90 days your first 90 minutes
create a tight bubble of total focus so
that no one can distract you turn off
your devices put them in a little
plastic bag put some reminders on your
door maybe some post-it notes that this
is my type bubble of total focus for the
next 90 minutes tell your team tell your
loved ones maybe get it put a Do Not
Disturb sign on your door they'll laugh
and explain it to them that for the next
90 days I will spend 90 minutes away
from distraction away from technology
away from interruptions focusing on my
magnum opus focusing on the genius
project that I want to bring into the
world because I will never mail it in I
will always bring it on and I'm gonna do
this for the next 90 minutes I'm gonna
optimize it and iterate it every day and
I'm gonna bring my full bandwidth
because what makes a genius they all
have one trait in common they were able
to spend extended periods of time in
isolation focused mono maniacally on
their most valuable project rule number
eight become a valuable person well
you've heard me talk about the 2 X 3 X
mindset so to double your income and
your impact
triple your investment including your
time investment in two core areas your
personal mastery and your professional
capabilities you see when you work on
your personal mastery you awaken your
mind set your heart set your health set
in your soul set and when you get those
four Interior empires to world class you
become a force of nature out in the
world and you do epic things so you want
to work on your personal mastery like
you're doing here with me right now by
listening to this episode and then the
second thing you want to do is you want
to work on your professional capability
you want to be the heavyweight champion
of your game you want to dial in your
sport whether your sport is
entrepreneurship whether your sport is
being a chef whether your sport is being
a coder whether your sport is being a
manager whether you're an entrepreneur a
CEO and astronaut a poet I don't know
what it is but when you focus on your
personal mastery and your professional
capability and you really work on those
I'm talking about hours every day if you
are serious about leading the field what
starts to happen is this you become a
vastly more valuable person you become
very aware and that's why I say
education is inoculation against
disruption that's why I suggest you with
great love and respect leadership
belongs to the learners Maya Angelou
said it beautifully she said when you
know better you can do better
with better awareness you can make
better choices and with better choices
you're gonna see better results I mean
it's the awareness that you bring to
every day based on your learning based
on your investments in training well
what does that do it gives you the
ability to a to make better choices
better decisions when you look at a
great life it's just a series of
beautiful choices done daily stacked on
over time and so when you get great
awareness heightened awareness or acute
awareness of what it means to be a
leader an elite performer and a player
an awesome human being an epic
do sir a fit human being a loving human
it just goes it on would that awareness
via your learning you can make better
decisions every day better choices rule
number nine learn to say no what makes a
great company is less about your good
opportunities and a lot more about you
having the bravery and discipline to say
no to you to your many good
opportunities what destroys a great
company is actually opportunity bloating
too many good opportunities so literally
you diffuse your team's bandwidth and
you get distracted you see with so many
companies right now they they sort of
found their sweet pocket and they were
absolutely winning in their marketplace
and they decided to go hmm we've got
this app that is really changing the
game and owning the marketplace let's
get into food delivery let's get into
this let's get into that it happened to
General Electric as well you probably
know they decided at one point if we
can't be one or two in any market we're
gonna get out of that market that's the
key point I'm trying to make no you're
mighty mission no your monomaniacal
focus and then have the discipline to
say no to everything else so you can
lock and load on your finest opportunity
to completely change the game and rule
number ten the last time before some
special bonus clips make your I gained
larger than your IQ I remember being in
Soho New York and I walked into one of
their stories and I bought a coat and I
was leaving on an airplane for home
later that day and I asked the person
who was taking care of me I said is it
possible that's a great respectful way
to ask for something is it possible to
get this coat hemmed and adjust it a
little bit for me and he and and I said
the thing is that I'm leaving later
today and he looked at me and I've never
forgotten it because we all have these
people in their lives who say one thing
or show up in a certain way and they
stay with us for the rest of
they're our lives and he said to me
these words he said it I'd love to do
that for you I'd love to do that for you
and again the whole brain type - I'm
trying to deconstruct here is make your
ICANN larger than your IQ you know I
remember being in Prague and I asked
someone on the other again I spent a lot
of time in hotels and I said is it
possible to do this and here was the
reply on the other end of the phone I
think was someone from the front desk or
maybe it was room service and I try to
eat as clean as possible so probably it
was a request could I have olive oil and
fresh lemon or lemon as the salad
dressing and here's the reply just
really lovingly and respectfully and
hopefully fluently and elegantly
bringing this leadership inside home to
you I said is this possible and his
reply was anything is possible so it's
really easy to get seduced and stuck
into a mindset of can't you know someone
says let's start a new business someone
says here's a great poetic project that
if we release it to the world
will help us own our marketplace and it
sounds very obvious again but ask
yourself this is your default reply a
symptom of a mindset of Kant or do you
have a mentality of possibility when
someone says here read this book do you
shift into Kant or can when someone says
hey you know what I'm amped to run a
marathon you know I can't is that your
default setting in your neurobiological
hardwiring or do you go absolutely or
I'd love to do this you know it's really
really important and that is one of the
core distinctions of leadership isn't it
now I've got two really valuable bonus
clips for you from Robin Sharma around
using your most valuable hours wisely
and turning your pain into power but
before that my question of the day from
you is I want to know have you read any
of Robin Sharma's books and if so what
is your favorite one and why leave it
down the comments below I'm really
curious to find out thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love I'll see you soon and enjoy the
bonus clips
every great hero was broken if you were
look at Nelson Mandela
he suffered more than most people if you
look at mother Teresa she went through
incredible adversity over the course of
her journey if you were to study Mahatma
Gandhi Nelson Mandela Rosa Parks
Shakespeare and Tolstoy if you look at
any great artist a Picasso jean-michel
Basquiat if you look at the great world
builders they all suffered let let me
put it to you this way with great love
and respect they all out suffered the
majority and what I'm suggesting to you
is pain can be transformed into power
with the intention to transform pain
into power you see what most people do
is this is why most good people lose
they stumble and they fall and they
become heartbroken or disappointed by
life's challenges that happens to every
single one of us I mean just to be very
authentic as I always want to be in
these mastery sessions episodes I've
gone through a lot of hardship in my
life when I was you know going through
school very few people believed in me
and I was dismissed and called very very
average and the principal at the school
I was at said you're not even gonna get
into University and you might know my
backstory on the monk who sold his
Ferrari but that was a self-published
book and I was at the American
Booksellers conference in Chicago with a
cover of one of my books over my around
my neck shaking hands with all the
agents that were coming up the escalator
and when I was a self-published author
and I used to go into bookstores and say
would you take three copies of my book
I'll sign them could you put it on the
shelf and I was treated rudely and I was
laughed at and I was on radio shows and
I was ridiculed and then I've gone
through a lot of personal pain in my own
life and I've been on the top of the
mountain of victory and I must tell you
I have walked the lonely path in the
darkness in the valley of darkness but
me the great philosopher said it so
beautifully he said allow your heart to
be broken over and over and over until
it opens and what I'm suggesting to you
is really to dial into this insight all
great heroes have been broken but rather
than blaming 27 years in imprisonment in
the case of Nelson Mandela rather than
blaming his naysayers and his detractors
in the case of a mahathma gandhi rather
than saying life is hard why isn't isn't
greatness easy in the case of a mother
Teresa or Martin Luther King jr. rather
than saying why did this happen to me in
the case of Rosa Parks who refused to
give up her seat to someone on a bus
because she was being treated like a
second-class citizen because of the
color of her skin these great ones all
had one thing in common they leveraged
their pain and the power they turned
their tragedies into victories you wake
up every morning with full bandwidth
that's your mental focus your physical
energy and your willpower but every time
you check your email you diminish your
your bandwidth if you make another
choice that's weak versus powerful you
diminish your bandwidth as you go
through your morning when your bandwidth
is at its highest according to the
research what you start to do is if
you're making weak choices you're gonna
start getting weak results so never
check email first thing in the morning
never get on the social media first
thing in the morning use your most
valuable hours for your most valuable
activities
world's long media the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be to
like a little beacon pay believe nation
if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details
[Music]